what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so picking up with the conclusion
of no justice uh we kind of get a bit of
a jump here this is kind of ssin you
think in the last video we had talked
about how at the end of the story you
basically had the destruction of coal
more or less you know there's this
planet that was inhabited by the race to
Brainiac belong to and we didn't really
know what happened to the Justice League
at this point we pick up with the source
wall and it's kind of interesting here
because their groups just somewhat there
now in truth it's not like Snyder just
kind of grabs this out of nowhere it's
not like you know and then suddenly
they're at the source wall for no real
reason whatsoever it just sounds cool it
doesn't really fit in that way instead
what's going on here is remember all
this stuff stems from the source wall
that the source wall had basically been
broken it had been damaged now this
again is really Scott Snyder kind of
breaking away from the status quo
because historically speaking in DC
Comics this source wall is what
separates the main DC Universe from like
all the other universes that are out
there and the idea is that beyond the
source wall is just the source the
source of all things that exists but it
was always ambiguous and we were never
really told explicitly what it was if
you go back and you read the old Jack
Kirby like fourth world stories you're
more or less kind of told the source
more or less seems to be God but again
we're not really given a definitive
answer we're just kind of told that it's
there but with the source wall being
broken all these dangers are more or
less pouring into the universe and the
whole basis behind this is that it
really gives Scott Snyder almost
infinite resources here it gives them
infinite villains to throw into the to
the Justice League universe with Justice
League stories because what we do know
of a few people like super [ __ ] who
were locked inside the source wall most
people we don't know anything about
they've always just kind of been
backdrops they've been like universal
constants to the idea that they're just
stuck in the source wall and we don't
really know how they got there
and so because of this there's all kinds
of storytelling that can be Co up can be
told now of course with the arrival of
the Omega Titans on earth comes the SOS
of green arrow Oliver Queen basically
being one of the last few heroes who
were on earth really one of the only
heroes who are on earth everybody else
kind of dealing with the conflict out in
space he of course sends an SOS out to
the Green Lantern Corps says hey look
the Omega Titans are here and we're all
gonna die and so this really kind of
leads into like the aftermath of what's
going on with regards to the destruction
of colu and the reason why the reason
why this is the case is because when you
pick up with these various members of
these different Justice League teams for
the most part they're all dealing with
what essentially amounts to a
catastrophic failure and while it's not
necessarily a failure in the worst way
it is
failure because in their minds they were
all brought together for the singular
purpose of trying to save this planet
and defeat the Omega Titans there at
least learn as much as they could in
order to ensure the Omega Titans were
defeated the problem with this is that
it didn't work out that way of course we
know if collude was essentially
destroyed entirely but what also ended
up happening here is it was the Justice
League who was thrown into a situation
where their only real source of
knowledge which came in the form of
Brainiac was destroyed by Amanda Waller
and so they were literally flying blind
so you can't really fault him for
messing up here and for screwing up
that's just kind of the nature of things
when you don't really have all the
information available but at this point
they begin turning their attention to
Brainiac 2.0 the the son more or less a
Brainiac himself and when the questions
asked can you help us out here this is
when Snyder's starts to draw on this
sort of darker evil persona of a
Brainiac to point out when he basically
says no but here's the funny thing about
this one the reason why I love Snyder
writing it's not like this stereotypical
villain like well no because I'm a bad
guy and that's what I do bad people
fight against superheroes and I'm just
gonna make life of rough on you that's
not the stance he takes instead what he
really kind of argues here is the truth
of the of the situation is that you guys
have failed here I mean you know it was
it's inevitable you guys were gonna fail
sure I could help you but why would I
like you guys started all this this all
happened because of everything that
happened in in Dark Knight's metal had
you guys not broken the source wall then
none of this would have been a problem
so you guys are basically getting your
just desserts
you're getting the consequence of your
own actions and that's kind of the
interesting thing here because when you
look at the Justice League in terms of
their team as they've existed in the
various members who are part of it it
always seems to kind of follow this form
and function of like a villain shows up
and they fight the villain and they win
and the day is saved and this is kind of
a cool situation because it's like but
the Justice League isn't really as great
as they think they are but they're not
really that spectacular they're heroes
who do great things sure but they've
screwed up catastrophic Lee not only
that all this is because of them this is
all led to like them like like literally
this all starts with them and so it's
really kind of saying like you guys get
your Just Desserts now in reality it's
basically holding seven billion people
accountable for the actions of a handful
but that's kind of the price you pay
when you're when you just sort of hand
things over to the Justice League and
say run with it you know just just make
sure we save safe you know that's kind
of the way these things go and so
ultimately rule docs actually takes his
leave of the ship and simply says I'm
not fixing anything and actually ends up
traveling back to earth and this is kind
of cool because when he arrives here
initially he sort of hits up Amanda
Waller right says look you know you
understand the nature of things you did
to my father or killed you know kill
Brainiac and I'm gonna kill you in turn
which of course you know results in the
arrival of the of the Green Lantern
Corps now the Green Lantern Corps
showing up here of course in response to
the SOS but it's one of these things
where it doesn't really seem like they
could do a whole lot and that's one of
the things that's kind of cool here
about these Omega Titans away the
started drawing or really designs them
is they're kind of like this essence of
the universe itself like they're a
universal constant a backdrop they can't
defeat it any more than like the
universe itself can be defeated and so
because that's the case the Green
Lantern court while they are cool and
they are incredibly powerful ultimately
won't really be able to do a whole lot
here in fact that's one of the things
that's addressed you know world Docs
basically says hey it's cool you guys
are here whatever I don't really care
because you guys can't do anything to
stop this now Amanda Waller's response
is a lot more heavy-handed what she does
is she basically sat down and she had
like nuclear weapons tied to all these
trees and her belief was that if the
trees were destroyed then the Omega
Titans would leave because the trees
growing there the only reason why the
Omega Titans have arrived and so it's
kind of interesting because if anything
Amanda Waller has and will always be
cutthroat she is ruthless she'll do
whatever it takes to save the world and
when the response is made of like think
of the death toll he'll have in this
though the response of Amanda Waller is
but that's minuscule and she's not wrong
like the needs of the many outweigh the
needs of the few now of course this goes
directly into cyborg really having his
big moment and this is kind of the cool
thing because the justice league starts
to recall that like Brainiac his
database is on earth and this is when
Oliver Queen steps up and says yes it's
because Amanda Waller downloaded it
prior to his death and so this is where
the Justice League begins to modify
itself and this is where we started to
step into them actually being heroes
because now they have more information
to operate on they actually have a plan
that they can form here and so they
really just kind of hand everything over
to over to cyborg and the question is
cyborg what do we do in cyborgs response
is well all the other trees are dying
except for the tree of entropy which
means the Omega Titan is going to
consume that tree and so what we have to
do or at least what we figured at what
cyborg figured out anyway is that what
the Omega Titans are actually doing is
they're feeding on the seeds that are
born on these trees that when you have
the all four trees that begin to grow
one of them will outgrow the others the
others will die and whatever the nature
of the planet is if it's wisdom or
entropy or mystery or what-have-you that
tree will grow that tree will sprout
seeds and that's what the Omega Titans
feed on and so the response of cyborg is
just like fast-track to growth of the
seeds like grow those seeds as fast as
Paul
and then supercharged them with energy
of entropy and then feed it to the Omega
Titan and it's actually a really really
cool plan here because the hope of
cyborg is that with the with the Omega
Titan basically being satiated with all
this energy because these Omega Titans
aren't really like thinking beans which
is to say they're not really like
humanoid in a sense then the argument of
cyborg is they simply operate more on
instinct and the instinct is feed on
planets that are rich in whatever that
Omega Titan stands for and so if the
other Omega Titans see the one of
entropy and then they realize that it's
filled with all this entropic energy and
the responses consume that that Omega
type notice be drawn to that energy and
they'll consume it it takes their
attention away from planet Earth
now the other funny thing about this
this is actually one of the things that
I'm sad about is that DC seems to be
moving more in the direction of lex
luthor becoming a bad guy and the reason
why is because entropy is really just
kind of like chaos lawlessness a lack of
order and so what when you have someone
like selected like Lex Luthor who really
does stand for like being a hero and
then Deathstroke says I can't give this
thing to work and in turn Lex Luthor
takes it and charges it what seems to be
going on here as DC is continually
pointing to the direction of the idea
that Lex Luthor is gonna become a bad
guy I personally don't like it I think
you know sitting Lex Luthor back to
being a bad guy it's just kind of like
sitting things back to the way they were
before telling the same old stories that
we've seen before and so ultimately what
the end up doing is of course putting
this supercharged seed inside of a giant
sphere that's created by the Green
Lantern's and firing it off into the
entropy Omega Titan which in turn
literally overcharges it with more
energy than it could handle and blows it
up but here's the funny thing on the
surface we would look at this and we
would say hooray the day is saved that
Justice League won like we would all
celebrate and we would all be happy but
the reality of this is that Martian
Manhunter kind of looks at everything
that's gone on and even when Lex Luthor
kind of addresses this you know and and
it really speaks with Martian Manhunter
they both kind of come to this
realization that this was one the tip of
the iceberg and two they fractured the
universe yet again they made the same
mistake they made before and the reason
why is because these are mega Titans are
a fundamental force of the universe so
that's why I say they're very much like
Galactus when you look at Galactus and
Marvel Comics he's a force of nature
that was established in the trial of
Reed Richards Galactus serves the
purpose of maintaining cosmic balance by
consuming worlds that would otherwise
give birth to more Celestials who in
turn would over populate the universe
when it comes to these Omega Titans in
DC Comics they serve a universal
constant they keep the population of the
universe in check by feeding on
planets basically by literally keeping
the universe from being overrun with
life with the Justice League looking at
things from a narrowed perspective what
they basically done is they've offset
that balance planets that are basically
rich in entropy will continue on
thriving and growing and well that's not
necessarily the worst thing
overpopulation is one hell of a thing
and that's what you run into in this
universe is the idea that there's
basically gonna be more people than
there needs to be and so as a result the
Justice League has done more harm on a
much larger and grander scale and they
could possibly ever imagine but because
they're human because they're heroes
because they're looking at things from a
very small perspective they can't really
see the bigger picture so again it is
kind of intriguing here now of course
this leads directly into things like the
return of the Hall of Justice and a few
little follow-ups it'll actually really
be featured more in Justice League
number one if the interviews that Scott
Snyder has done are to be believed but
this is kind of cool because from here
what snyder does is he really kind of
breaks it down this is very reminiscent
of the old x-men comics like you read
the old x-men comics after decimation
and after the events running all the way
up until like Messiah Complex and then
it's break them off into more x-men
stories that's what's going on here and
in fact really within DC itself this is
more akin to the post-crisis landscape
in the sense that you originally had
Justice League International and in
Justice League Europe and then extreme
justice and all these different teams
that existed out there what's happening
is that in the aftermath of this whole
thing because teams have basically been
formed these teams are essentially going
to continue on in the same capacity
Wonder Woman's joining Justice League
dark you've got a new team called
Justice League Odyssey which really
seems to be more of a modified Justice
League International featuring cyborg
and Starfire and a few other characters
and then you've got the main Justice
League team so again it continues on in
in really kind of branches off into
three new titles which actually look
pretty awesome but it is an interesting
take on things I mean this of course was
clearly a story designed to springboard
into Justice League number one proper
but I imagine it was really a sniper's
way of just kind of creating a small
story for himself and then going into
the main Justice League title it's a
great story I loved it ah but still it
is kind of cool and it is a pretty
interesting set of events but without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]